hello children we're going to watch
today the trailer
for the chucky tv series i've been
hearing a lot about this show for
quite some time the original creators
involved right absolutely
that's what i like to hear keeping it
alive that's what i like to hear
yes came out while i was out of town so
let's see what's going on
[Music]
everyone has a halloween they'll always
remember
jake you went to vintage no i'm in the
retro oh
what's the difference about 10 bucks
look at that someone took the butcher
knife
[Music]
ugh
[Music]
[Music]
don't forget your boy
well guess what [ __ ] now the joke's
on you
oh no devin someone knows
what did you do
oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look around it's the world series
[Music]
[Music]
if
[Music]
i'm gonna go kill your sister wanna come
why are you sleepy
oh no well that looks fun
absolutely looks like it's towing that
line between like you know a bit of the
camp but also going hard on the kills
i don't know about towing the line i
think it's doing both like a hundred
thousand percent
yeah there's a lot of kills and a lot of
camp um fused into one bringing
chucky from film especially how the
films have progressed to where they're
at now to bring them over to tv
i get a little bit of some of that ryan
murphy flair to it
with the camp i get some of that meta
awareness you know what it unless
scream and more of uh oh what was that
movie
with negasonic teenage warhead and storm
where they're teenagers in high school
yeah yeah yeah i saw it you didn't see
it but you were more likely to remember
the title than i
am there it is on screen there's the
poster okay
but i got some of those vibes a little
bit more so weirdly
actually another thing that i got when
you're when you're bringing this back
more to the first film in the sense of
how a boy
you know misunderstood lonely sad
befriends a doll and five because has a
new best friend in this doll bringing it
back to there but putting it in the high
school format
i was actually getting vibes from carrie
uh being thrown into here how it's
building up to some big slaughter fest
except carrie who was not really
conflicted by the end of that film and
went full mayhem full chaos this guy
uh is certainly conflicted about the
progression of his best friend slash
doll
chucky yeah i've got a lot of a lot of
flares here that i find very enjoyable
feels really pulpy and i like the way
it's shot looks cool and it feels
different than the films while still
honoring the films too
yeah yeah it seems like it comes
naturally out of them in a tonal
sense but also yeah setting it in a sort
of new place although from what i
understand i mean you are going to have
andy in the series you are going to have
nika from the past couple films fiona
dora
and you got brad dorf back i heard
jennifer tilly's gonna return for this
too so like they've gone
a lot of effort uh in the past couple of
installments of the films at least to
bring it back to something more
resembling the horror and less
resembling the sort of
wackiness and and like full-on camp of
the bride and seed of chucky movies
yeah like the only thing that stood out
about this trailer is like i wonder what
the explanation is gonna be for this
like
legit high school ass teenager bringing
the toy to school just like
seeing him science class with chucky on
the bed on the stool i was a little bit
like
okay that's a little funky like that
seems like you need him
to bring the doll here to get some kills
happening but
i mean i'm absolutely gonna wait for the
context and yeah i mean i like the idea
of expanding upon this especially with
what i understand about the
previous couple movies like even
fracturing
chucky's ability or at least charles lee
ray's ability to inhabit multiple chucky
bodies and stuff like that seems like
there's a lot of mayhem
that can come this way and also i'm just
glad for don mancini and company because
you know there was some controversy
about the film
and you know them not being involved
with that and that being sort of a
studio i mean the remake
the remake film yeah yeah the child's
play 20
whatever that was but yeah this looks
really cool i'm excited i'm excited for
it too
uh is because of everyone like you said
who's gonna be involved this seems like
with the marketing of this
i thought it would be more nostalgia
heavy with the way they would do this
like this is for the chucky fans and
this is for you guys but really
even though it is a continuation now
like you said everyone is going to be
coming back for this i thought they're
really smart with how to do this trailer
because it feels more like a reboot
but if you know that it's not yeah yeah
it helps so that way you don't feel like
i have to watch a gazillion chucky
movies
uh for the first time or again in order
to keep up with a series which is going
to be more involved with its
storytelling because there's multiple
episodes i am curious to see if they can
maintain
a strong story that's the thing with tv
you gotta have compelling storytelling
to keep you coming back every single
week
when you're dealing with a show format
it's not the same as dealing with a fun
80-minute or 90-minute
silly horror movie about a doll like
like child's play one and two i think
are pretty great after that they kind of
teetered down
some are all right they've come back up
in the reasons yeah exactly especially
the latest straight to dvd one delay
couple yeah either way i think the main
character looks cool i think it looks
fine like
i feel like i could be invested in what
he's going through i
think the whole thing would bring in the
doll to high school it's all just a
matter of tone
that's really yeah that's really what it
comes down to and i feel like they're
striking the right tone here
and just at least romans communicated in
this trailer
and i liked that they didn't feel the
need to pack it with cameos of actors to
come back
like they really led with here's the new
story and we're just going to go with
that and i like that and i what i really
want is a red band trailer i want to see
the gore i want to see how good
it's got to be some great gorilla of
course of course man of course
in this non-ethnically diverse high
school that's right where's your virtues
kill those white kids well leave your
thoughts down below are you excited for
this chucky show
well most will probably react to when i
imagine
that subscribe click that bell hit that
like button we'll catch you guys soon